Die zwei Sprechstunden.
Von wo rufst du an?
Ich ruf aus Berlin an.
Aus Berlin, aus Berlin, ne, den will ich jetzt nicht machen. Du hast eine Frage zum Thema PIN auf der Bankkarte.
Ja, Frage-Feststellung. Es wird vorhin gesagt worden, die PIN wäre auf den modernen Bankkarten, nicht mehr drauf, oder mal Jespro-Karten. Hat sich denn beim CCC jemand mal Gedanken gemacht, wie das Verfahren Chip-Offline funktioniert?
Ja, also es ist nicht mehr ein Magnetstreifen drauf, das war denke ich gemeint.
Ach, das war gemeint, genau. Aber das bedeutet doch, die PIN ist ja letztendlich auf dem Chip oder im Chip gespeichert.
Ja, aber nicht unbedingt als PIN. Also zum einen hast du das Problem, dass der Chip dir nicht erlaubt ist, auszulesen, was drauf gespeichert ist, sondern du musst da dann anfangen, irgendwie mit Säuren und Mini-Nadeln und so weitererrum zu stochern, um überhaupt was auslesen zu können. Und dann ist in der Regel nicht die PIN gespeichert, sondern so eine Art Prüf-Simulator drauf. Also in dem einen Verfahren verschlüsselt man die PIN mit sich selber zum Beispiel. Oder die PIN wird mit einem kartenspezifischen Schlüssel verschlüsselt, der aber nicht auf der Karte gespeichert ist zum Beispiel.
So, der Matheleistungskurs hat zwei Stunden Zeit, um zu erklären und das mal darzulegen und dann an der Tafel auszurechnen.
Also es bedeutet, dass wenn einem jetzt eine Karte mit Chip in die Hände fällt, man eigentlich keine Möglichkeit hat, die PIN so auszulesen, dass man die Karte trotzdem verwenden kann.
So ist es im Prinzip gedacht.
Also vielleicht ein ganz kurzer Einwurf dazu. Es gab ja diese Sendung gestern Abend, wo auch so ein bisschen der Eindruck erweckt wurde, dass das aktuelle Sicherheitsproblem, was mit dem Chip zu tun haben könnte, da will ich vielleicht nochmal kurz erwähnen, dass viele Fälle, die für die Recherche da vorgelegen haben, die also gar keinen Chip drauf hatten. Es ist also kein Problem, dass grundsätzlich dieser Chip irgendwie einen Anzeichen oder die Chance erhöhen könnte, dass da jetzt ein Sicherheitsproblem ist, dass jemand diese PIN erraten könnte. Bei den Fällen, die wir jetzt kennen, ist da kein Zusammenhang herzustellen.
Ja, also gut, jetzt wollte ich mir nochmal noch einmal nachraten mit der PIN auf dem Chip, weil das vorhin so ein bisschen unklar war, dass die PIN halt nicht auf der Karte überhaupt drauf wäre.
Wobei, also vielleicht nochmal, so gut, dass du es auch nochmal anbringst, es gibt auch zwei unterschiedliche Verfahren bei dem EC oder bei diesem Offline-Prüfung, bei diesem EC-Karten mit Chip. Da ist eins, das sogenannte passive Verfahren, das ist auch vor, ich glaube, zwei Jahren ging das mal durch die Medien. Da haben Leute auch geschafft, die Kommunikation zwischen Lesegerät und Chip mitzuschneiden und da auch die Authentifizierung des Gerätes, die eigentlich gemacht werden sollte, wieder sozusagen aufzunehmen und wieder einzuspielen und damit ein falsches Lesegerät vortäuschen und so Geschichten. Das sind Chips, die aber eigentlich theoretisch nicht im Einsatz sein sollten, die aber von einigen Banken doch aus Kostengründen verwendet worden sind. Ob das Ganze jetzt praxisrelevant ist, kann ich nicht beurteilen, weil der Aufwand ist schon relativ groß, das zu machen. Und wahrscheinlich sind also diese 90% klassischen Skimming-Fälle, wo also der Magnetstreifen abgefischt wird und die Pin irgendwie abgefilmt wird beim Eingeben, sind da wahrscheinlich eher ein größeres Problem. Und zwar noch irgendwas wollte ich noch zu pinnen offline. Ja gut, die Banken stellen übrigens deswegen nicht um. Das ist deren Argumentation. Die könnten ja sagen, okay, jetzt 30 Jahre Magnetstreifen ist genug. Wir stellen jetzt auf Chip um, weil das ist sicherer, weil das ist so, dass das Lesegerät sich auch, also das Gerät, wenn ich jetzt irgendwo einkaufen gehe und da meine Schuhe irgendwo im Laden bezahlen will mit EC-Karte, dann stecke ich in so ein sogenanntes POS, Point of Sale Terminal rein. Und die Dinger sind eigentlich schon ziemlich sicher, die in Deutschland stehen. Andererseits weiß ich natürlich als Kunde gar nicht, ob das Gerät auch wirklich ein POS-Terminal ist oder irgendwie nicht nur ein umlackierter Taschenrechner, wo ich dann irgendwie meine PIN-Eintippe-Karte reingestecke und zack, Daten sind weg. Das sind Fälle, die gibt es auch zu Tausenden, passieren die. Das ist ein ganz großes Missbrauchsproblem. Und deswegen könnte man sagen, okay, Chip darf also nur die Sachen, darf überhaupt nur mit dem Lesegerät sprechen, wenn sich das Lesegerät ordentlich bei dem Chip identifiziert als ein echtes Lesegerät. Da ist irgendwie auch so ein Hochsicherheitsmodul drin. Das ist auch echtes, ordentliches Stück Technik, was sich ja sofort selbst zerstört, wenn man das irgendwie anbohrt und so Geschichten. Da sind also dann diese geheimen Schlüssel drin, um mit der Karte zu kommunizieren. Also alles ziemlich komplex, aber an sich ist die Chip-Geschichte schon ganz gut. Aber es ist natürlich wahnsinnig aufwendig. Wenn man sagt, wir wollen jetzt vom Magnetstreifen weg und wollen weltweit alle Geräte umstellen, ist das natürlich ein riesen Batzen Geld, den die Banken da investieren müssen. Und das müsste eigentlich auf einen Schlag passieren oder möglichst auf einen Schlag. Und bisher konnten sich die Banken da noch nicht auf ein ordentliches Umstiegsszenario einigen. Und es ist nicht so, dass es ein Problem nur in Deutschland ist mit dem Magnetstreifen, sondern es ist weltweit ein Problem. Aber offensichtlich scheint der Leidensdruck noch nicht groß genug zu sein, weil die Gerichte, wenn dann Missbrauch passiert, leider immer noch für die Banken und gegen den Kunden entscheiden würden. Wenn jetzt die Gerichte sagen würden, ey Banken jetzt 30 Jahre Magnetstreifen, Schluss jetzt, Feierabend, macht Chip, und ihr müsst jetzt dem Kunden Geld erstatten, dann würden die Banken sich jetzt wahrscheinlich ein bisschen schneller überlegen.
Ja gut, aber das ist ja auch so ein bisschen ein deutsches Problem. Also wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel mal guckt in Frankreich oder Großbritannien, werden der Kreditkarten grundsätzlich noch mit Chip ausgegeben. In Frankreich ist es zum Beispiel so, dass man sogar bei der Kreditkarte, bei einer inländischen, französischen Karte den PIN eingeben muss, um mit der Karte zu bezahlen. Also ich hab auch so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass es auch so ein bisschen daran liegt, dass die Deutschen sich das so ein bisschen gemütlich gemacht haben.
Ja total, auf jeden Fall. Also die sagen halt immer, naja, wir müssen die deutschen Karten, die müssen ja auch irgendwie Magnetstreifen haben, weil die Leute wollen ja auch im Ausland. Aber dann könnte man sagen, okay, wenn ich als normaler Bürger irgendwie, ich brauch nicht ins Ausland, ich bin halt in Deutschland und ich will einfach für Deutschland eine sichere Karte haben, dann wäre das auch durchaus machbar. Wenn ich sag, okay, ich will jetzt im Ausland auch, dann hol ich meine extra Karte, wo ein Magnetstreifen ist. Da gelten dann irgendwie, die kann dann auch nicht in Deutschland benutzt werden und so Geschichten. Das wäre ja schon alles denkbar. Das ist natürlich ein bisschen mehr Aufwand, kostet ein bisschen mehr Geld, aber offensichtlich scheint der Leidensdruck bei den Banken noch nicht groß genug zu sein.
EC-Karte, weil Sie gesagt haben, also Dinge heißen ja inzwischen Magestro-Karte, nicht mehr EC-Karte.
Ja, aber unter uns ist das quasi dasselbe, oder?
Ja, genau, ja klar. Aber die Dinge heißen halt. Aber was ich Ihnen sagen wollte, der Tipp ist eigentlich der, weil vorhin gesagt worden ist, man könnte die nicht ohne PIN bestellen. Das stimmt nicht ganz. Also ich weiß zumindest von den ost- und norddeutschen Sparkassen, die am selben Rechenzentrum dranhängen, dass sie dort technisch die Möglichkeit haben, die Karte ohne PIN zu bestellen. Das Problem ist nur, dass die meisten Leute, also die meisten Berater in den Filialen nicht wissen, dass es geht. Aber es geht.
Ich glaube, wir waren nicht bei den Maestro-Karten, sondern wir waren bei Kreditkarten.
Genau, aber das ist ein Punkt. Man kann das natürlich auch machen. Man kann sagen, zur Bank gehen, hier ist der Briefumschlag irgendwie. Bitte bestätigen Sie mir, dass Sie den unversehrt empfangen haben. Und dann bin ich natürlich auch raus aus der Sache.
Gut, Alex, danke dir. Alles klar, gerne. Schönen Abend, tschüss. Mir fällt jetzt siebenteils ein, dass es 10 nach 11 ist und wir haben noch nicht ein einziges Mal deinen mit unglaublich technischem Aufwand hergestellten Sound des Kartenlesegerätes gehört. Also bitte, lauschen Sie jetzt. Der nächste am Telefon ist Mike. Hallo Mike.
Hallo.
Grüß dich, was ist deine Frage?
Ich hab Probleme mit meiner IC-Karte. Und zwar, also wird die nicht richtig ausgelesen. Also ich hab das jetzt eh mal erlebt bei so einem Druckgerät. Da hat der die nicht gelesen. Und dann bin ich zu so einem Automaten, Bankautomaten, gesagt.
Du meinst so einem Kontoausdrucksdrucker.
Dann bin ich zu so einem Automaten gegangen, also der Bargeld aussehen hat. Der hat die wieder gelesen. Und da war heute so ein mobiler Lieferdienst. Und der wollte meine EC-Karte auch lesen. Und da hat er die wieder nicht auslesen können.
Da musst du einfach mal zur Bank gehen. Hast du dich vielleicht irgendwie ein bisschen draufgesetzt oder mal ein bisschen nah an die große Lautsprecherbox gekommen bei der Party oder so?
Bei Bezahlen annehmen?
Also äußerlich ist das alles...
Ne, Magnetstreifen siehst du nicht. Siehst du ja bei einer Kassette auch nicht, ob da was drauf ist oder nicht.
Also zur Bank gehen und dann nochmal umtauschen.
Kriegst du eine neue.
Und was muss man eigentlich genau achten? Was darf nicht passieren? Also nehmen...
Alles was stärker Magnetfelder erzeugen.
Radio, also...
Meistens nicht, aber Lautsprecherboxen kommen große...
Fernseher, also Röhrenfernseher auch nicht drauflegen.
Alte Fernseher im Kaufhaus, die Diebstahlsicherungsabmachgeräte.
Das hat schon einen Grund, da steht immer hier keine Kreditkarten und EC-Karten drauflegen. Das ist schon ernst gemeint, das solltet ihr nicht tun.
Sonst machst du plupp und da ist nix mehr drauf.
Genau.
So wie wahrscheinlich bei dir jetzt passiert. Bist du irgendwo an den Magneten vorbeigelaufen?
Oder die hat mal in der Sonne gelegen, was auch immer.
0331 70 97 110 Chaosradio auf Fritz. Wir reden über Plastikkarten, auf denen Daten gespeichert werden. Wenn ihr mal wissen wolltet, was steht da eigentlich drauf, ruft uns an. Der nächste ist Tom. Hallo. Hallo. Von wo rufst du an?
Aus Berlin-Rundchenhausen.
Aus Rundchenhausen.
Und meine Frage ist, ich hatte mal vor nicht allzu langer Zeit einen Fernsehbericht gesehen. Da hatten sie Berichte über manipulierte Lesegeräte in Tankstellen, Supermärkten und so weiter. Wo dann praktisch, während man seinen Einkauf bezahlt hat, dass alles mitgelesen wurde und dann per E-Mail an irgendwelche Adressen im Ausland verschickt wurden und dann, was vorhin schon gesagt wurde, im Ausland mit solchen Rohlingen dann halt abgehoben wurde. Kann man sich da irgendwie verschützen?
Nee, kannst du nicht. Das ist auch noch ein Grund mehr, warum dieser Magnetstreifen endlich sterben muss, ist das Thema. Weil du einfach als Kundin nicht weißt, wo du deine Karte reinsteckst und wo du deine PIN eingibst. Also kann einfach auch sein, dass ein Geldautomat, da gab es auch schon Fälle, dass die Leute einfach einen komplett falschen Geldautomat hingestellt haben. Dann kamen halt irgendwie raus, wenn wir 50 Euro, sorry, mehr haben wir gerade nicht oder so. Und eine Minute später wurden dann 1000 Euro von einem Konto abgehoben. Also du kannst einfach nichts trauen, keinem Geräten trauen, wo du deine Karte reinsteckst. Das ist natürlich ein großes Dilemma. Natürlich macht man sich das auch. Aber es gibt keinerlei Möglichkeiten festzustellen, was da in diesem Gerät passiert mit deinen Daten.
Also dann jetzt nur noch mit Unterschrift bezahlen.
Das wäre eigentlich der sichere Weg, ja.
Aber nur mit Papierunterschrift, nicht mit solchen Unterschriftenpads.
Wobei da glaube ich die Beweiskraft auch nur so Mittel ist.
Der Nachteil ist vor allen Dingen, dass wenn sie das richtig aufzeichnen, sodass du den Winkel und den Andpressdruck des Stifts speicherst, dann kann im Prinzip jemand, der die Daten speichert, anschließend sich hinsetzen und basierend auf diesen Daten versuchen genau den gleichen Winkel und Andpressdruck nachzumachen und kann anschließend eine Papierunterschrift perfekt nachmachen, wo dann auch kein Experte mehr bezeugen kann, dass es nicht deine Unterschrift war.
Richtig. Wobei andererseits die Unterschriften, ich glaube die werden nicht, es gibt kein System, die die prüfen, oder? Also in der Regel kann man da mit drei Kreuzen unterschreiben.
Prüft werden sie nicht, aber es gab wohl mal Bestrebungen, das als biometrisches Merkmal einzuführen.
Also wie du persönlich den Stift hältst, welche Schrift.
Genau.
Wobei es gibt ja mittlerweile in Deutschland schon mehrere große Ketten, bei denen man, wenn du eine EC-Zahlung hast, also eine bargeldlose Zahlung, schon das von Hendrik angesprochene Terminal hast, wo du so ein Bildschirm hast, auf dem man dann unterschreiben muss, wo du nicht mehr auf dem Papier unterschreibst.
Kannst du mit Mickey Maus unterschreiben.
Und dann sagt dir, ne ne, dann sagt dir das Ding, die Unterschrift stimmt nicht, bitte machen sie es nochmal. Ne.
Aber wenn es jemand hat oder nochmal erklären kann, also sagt mir, wo so ein Ding steht, ich probier's aus, aber ich kann nicht.
Bei Parkstationen hab ich schon probiert, das heißt, bitte unterschreiben sie mit dem Finger auf dem Bildschirm, da hab ich schon mal kleine Bildchen gemalt. So ein Häuschen und eine Sonne, aber... Ich mein, wenn das Ding mich auffordert, auf dem Bildschirm zu malen.
Also diese Unterschriftprüfung, die funktioniert... Ihr kennt das ja auch, wenn ihr ein Paket bekommt von DHL oder UPS oder sowas, die halten euch so ein Ding hin, und da machst du halt irgendwie was auch immer, es kann eh kein Mensch lesen und auch nichts vergleichen oder so. Das ist eher so eine pro forma Geschichte. Aber beim Bezahlen... Glaube ich nicht. Also das... Guck mal kurz Henrik hier an. Also wie gesagt, würde mich sehr wundern, wenn...
Nehmt das mal als nächstes Projekt auf. Wir probieren das mal aus und halten euch da auf dem Laufenden. Warte mal, jetzt haben wir Johannes am Telefon. Hallo Johannes. Nee, wobei. Christian wartet länger. Johannes, bleib geduldig. Ich bin ja ein fairer Mensch. Hallo Christian.
Hallo.
Du rufst an aus Berlin.
Ja.
Sag mir deine Vorwahl.
Genau.
Mehr weiß ich über dich aber nicht, deswegen musst du deine Frage stellen.
Ja, also ich hab auch eine Mensakarte. Und zwar vom Studentenwerk Berlin, irgend so ein Ding. Und also erstmal hat mich interessiert, als eingeführt wurde, dass man nur noch mit dieser Mensakarte sich sein Essen kaufen darf. Ja, was da drauf gespeichert wird. Oder ob, da ist halt ein Geldbetrag drauf. Ob der im System gespeichert wird oder auf der Karte. Oder was...
Ob die Karte speichert, dass du kein Spinat essen magst.
Ja, zum Beispiel. Und ich hab's einfach nicht rausgekriegt. Also ich hab mehrere E-Mails an Studentenwerk geschrieben und hab da auf den Seiten und so geguckt, aber ich hab nichts rausgekriegt. Also ich hab keine Ahnung, was da, wo gespeichert wird.
Entschuldigung, hab ich grad nicht mitgekriegt. Kontaktlos?
Ja, Kontaktlos.
Dann ist das mit sehr großer Wahrscheinlichkeit MyFair Classic. Das setzen im Wesentlichen alle deutschen Universitäten ein, die solche Karten einführen. Also ist alles sehr beliebt. Und das sind Verfahren, wie ich schon erwähnte, was auf Security bei Obscurity basierte. Wir haben das Verschlüsselungsverfahren vor einiger Zeit reverse-ingeniert durch reingucken in die Karten. Das Verschlüsselungsverfahren ist bekannt. Und in absehbarer Zeit werden wir auch vorführen können, dass man einfach Karten lesen kann. Und bei diesen Karten, die sind extra entwickelt worden als solche Geldbörsenkarten für genau diese Anwendung in Mensen zum Beispiel. Die haben also eine spezielle Funktion. Also sie haben mehrere Sektoren, haben eine spezielle Funktion, dass du einen Block in so einem Sektor als Börse definieren kannst. Also dass da ein Geldbetrag drauf ist. Der wird dann direkt drauf gespeichert. Und du kannst dann definieren, dass das Erhöhung des Betrags und das Enhiedrigen des Betrags unterschiedlich gehandhabt werden. Mit verschiedenen Schlüsseln zum Beispiel. Aber was sie im Wesentlichen bei allen diesen Systemen noch zusätzlich dazu haben, dass sie den Geldbetrag auf der Karte speichern, ist ein Schattenkonto im Hintergrund. Um dann zum Beispiel, wenn du die Karte verloren hast, dir den Betrag wieder herstellen zu können. Also bei uns hier in Berlin ist es so, dass du da richtig Informationsblättchen dazu kriegst, dass du dir die Nummer, die auf der Karte draufstehst, irgendwo noch notieren sollst, sodass, wenn du die Karte verlierst, gehst du mit der Nummer einfach zum Studentenwerk. Sie überweisen dir den Betrag entweder auf eine neue Karte oder geben ihn dir so oder was auch immer und sperren deine alte Karte.
Oh, was ist da mit dem Informationsblättchen, was Henry gerade erwähnt hat?
Da, als es eingeführt wurde, lagen überall Blättchen raus und das wissen die auch an den Kassen alle. Und es hängen auch, sie haben relativ viel Werbung dazu gemacht und es steht auch alles auf der Webseite drauf.
Also wo war das? An welcher Uni?
Hier Berlin Studentenwerk, also alle Uni.
Ach so, aber ja okay, bei mir an der Uni...
Welche Uni ist denn das?
An der TfH, also Technische Fachhochschule. Da habe ich so ein Infoblatt nie gefunden. Ich wurde nur irgendwann mal unfreundlich darauf hingewiesen, hier geht jetzt nicht mehr mit Bargeld. Und dann musste ich halt mir irgendwie für 1, 60 Euro so eine Karte ausstellen lassen.
Oh, sie haben es erhöht. Es waren mal 1, 55 Euro.
Ja, das weiß ich nicht mehr. Vielleicht waren es auch 1, 55 Euro. Und musste da halt irgendeinen Betrag drauf zahlen.
Na Krissan, das ist doch die beste Möglichkeit, mal deinen lokalen Studentenwerkvertreter anzurufen und zu sagen, Kollege, wir haben keine Informationsblättchen, kümmer dich mal.
Genau. Also es steht auf der Webseite, aber eigentlich sollten auch über Informationen ausliegen, oder sie haben Plakate aufgehängt mit der Werbung für das neue System. Die sind lila.
Ja, so wie die Karte wahrscheinlich.
Vielleicht hört ja auch jemand vom Studentenwerk Berlin zu, hat dieses Manko erkannt und wird sich darum kümmern, dass diese Lücke sofort abgestellt wird. Die TfH in Berlin hat keine Informationen über die Geldkarte, die an die Studenten ausgegeben werden, vielleicht könnt ihr das bitte ändern. Vielen Dank.
Ja, also dazu, also zu der Karte muss ich noch sagen, ich finde es irgendwie extrem unpraktisch. Also vielleicht spart man damit an der Kasse ein paar Sekunden, weil man nicht nach seinem Kleingeld suchen muss. Aber irgendwie ist es blöde, wenn ich, also ich kann die Karte ja nur da benutzen und ich habe immer auch Geld in der Tasche, weil ich muss ja zwischendurch auch irgendwo anders Sachen einkaufen. Und wenn ich jetzt auf dieser Karte irgendwie nur noch 50 Cent drauf habe und mir aber einen Kakao für 80 Cent kaufen will und jetzt noch 40 Cent in der Tasche habe, dann funktioniert das nicht, weil diese Automaten, wo ich die Karte aufladen kann, die nehmen nur 50 Cent Stücke als kleines Geld.
Ja, ja, diese Karten sind sehr unpraktisch. Das haben wir auch festgestellt. Also früher ging es zumindest bei uns in Atlas Hof an der Universität noch so, dass du an den Karten mit Geld oder mit Karte, und wenn du nicht genau auf der Karte drauf hattest, haben sie es dir schnell auf die Karte draufgebucht. Das haben sie dann aber zum Anfang dieses oder des letzten Semesters auch abgeschafft. Zum Beispiel, ich lade immer 5 Euro auf meine Karte auf. Ich habe aber nur einen 10-Euro-Schein. Das Verfahren ist dann so, dass ich zur Kasse gehe, sage, ich möchte gerne 5 Euro aufladen. Dann sagen sie mir, nee, ich kann hier nicht aufladen, sondern geben mir für meinen 10-Euro-Schein zwei Fünfer. Mit einem der Fünfer gehe ich dann zum Automaten zurück, lade den Fünfer auf die Karte auf und gehe dann zur Kasse zurück, bezahle, was ich bezahlen wollte.
Ach, deswegen dauert Studieren so lange. Danke, Christian.
Ja, ich wollte dazu noch eine Frage stellen. Irgendwie beunruhigt mich bisher schon, dass ich halt den Betrag von der Karte abgebucht kriege, ohne dass ich irgendwo okay sage. Also die Frauen an der Kasse sagen immer recht unfreundlich, so jetzt Karte rauflegen hier und ich war noch nicht mal, also ich hab's noch nicht mal geschafft zu identifizieren, wo da jetzt auf dem Display der Betrag steht, der jetzt abgebucht wird.
Direkt beim Kartenauflegen. Ja. Ja, das Kartenterminal hat so ein kleines Display drin. Ja, genau.
Aber ich brauch halt immer irgendwie eine Sekunde, um zu sehen, welcher Betrag jetzt da steht. Und ich möchte halt sehen, was ich bezahle, wenn ich bezahle.
Na, das kannst du gleich reklamieren. Also das ist mir auch schon ein paar Mal passiert, dass irgendwie eine neue Kassiererin hat das falsch eingegeben. Wenn du es dann sofort sagst, die können tatsächlich noch Geld zurückbuchen.
Nein, also mir geht es einfach darum, dass ich eine Sekunde brauche. Ich werde aber von denen oft angeflaumt, dass ich halt zu langsam reagiere.
Na ja, da kann aber deine Karte ja in dem Fall nicht dafür. Das ist ja eher ein Kommunikationsproblem zwischen dir und deiner Kassiererin.
Die Mentalität, die dahinter steckt, stört mich ein bisschen. Also eigentlich wollen die von mir, dass ich sofort, wenn ich an die Kasse komme, meine Karte da auf dieses Lesegerät drauflege und die einfach den Betrag abbuchen können. Und das ganze Verfahren geht so schnell, also dass ich eine Sekunde Zeit habe, um zu checken, welcher Betrag wurde denn jetzt abgebucht. Okay, ich kann hinterher zum Lesegerät gehen.
Da waren bestimmt Roland Berger oder so ein Kandidat am Spiel, die gesagt haben, das kriegen wir noch drei Sekunden kürzer hin.
Aber du hast natürlich recht, ohne Authentisierung ist oder ohne irgendwelche Bestätigung des Karteninhabers ist bei diesen Karten tatsächlich sehr böse, denn man kann zum Beispiel so eine Art Wurmloch bauen. Also man baut eine Kartenfälschung, etwas, was so tut, als wäre es eine Karte und ein Lesegerät, verbindet die miteinander entweder über ein längeres Kabel oder über eine Funkverbindung und hat dann zwei Leute. Einer stellt sich an die Kasse bezahlt mit der falschen Karte und einer stellt sich mit dem falschen Lesegerät neben einer echten Karte, zum Beispiel neben deiner, weil er hinter dir in der Schlange steht. Und die Karte wird dann quasi, die falsche Karte tut dann so, als wäre es deine. Auch wenn sie nichts über deine Karte weiß, sie leitet einfach alles, was das Echte Lesegerät mit der falschen Karte sagt, leitet das falsche Lesegerät an die echte Karte weiter und die Antworten wieder zurück.
Dosentelefon 2.0.
Genau, das nennt man dann einfach Wurmloch, zum Beispiel nach dieser Analogie. Und damit kannst du dann im Prinzip bei allen kontaktlosen Karten, alle kontaktlosen Karten haben genau dieses Problem, vor allen Dingen, wenn sie halt die Abbuchung machen, ohne dass du noch mit PIN eingeben musst oder so. Dass du im Prinzip, wenn jemand sich an dich ranschleichen kann und dein falsches Lesegerät an dich ranhalten kann, wenn du zumindest solange wie in deiner Nähe ist, mit der Karte bezahlen.
Also er kann praktisch, wenn er vor mir in der Schlange steht, praktisch mit meiner Karte bezahlen, weil er die sozusagen verlängert mit dem Lesegerät, mit dem Lesegerät.
Christian, sei wachsam, weil wir haben jetzt noch ein paar Leute. Sei wachsam, deine Frage, pass auf deine Frage.
Für einen Bestätigungsknopf auf den Ding an, der erst die Antenne aktiviert.
Genau, das ist eine ganz, ganz großartige Idee. Bei RFID, das unterstützen wir auch voll und ganz, wäre eigentlich auch technisch nicht so aufwendig. Das würde diese ganzen Privatsphäre-Geschichten wahnsinnig erleichtern, wenn man einfach so einen kleinen Taster hätte auf der Karte, jetzt darfst du funken.
Mal gucken, ob du voll bist. Christian, bleib wachsam, sei lieb zu den Frauen in der Kantine. Der nächste am Telefon ist Johannes. Hallo Johannes.
Grüß dich. Ich wollte ja eigentlich ursprünglich was zu dem Thema Führerscheine sagen, aber weil ihr jetzt gerade bei dem Thema Studentenkarten seid, von dem Studentenwerken, das nenne ich gerade, ich habe es heute im Internet gelesen, und zwar ich studiere in Magdeburg an der Uni, und da ist ein Datensecker irgendwie passiert, da haben die diese gesamten Daten von den Studenten, also jetzt die gesamten Stammdaten und sowas, haben die online gestellt auf irgendeinen Server, und die waren halt öffentlich in...
Zwei Wochen lang.
Zwei Wochen lang, genau, die waren öffentlich zugänglich. Und dabei zählt mir nämlich gerade auf, dass auf unserem Studentenausweis ist es ja so, dass ich mit diesem Studentenausweis sowohl in die Bibliothek gehen kann, als auch nicht über online einloggen kann, über diese Nummer, die ich da drin habe, bzw. auch, im Grunde meine gesamten Daten, die ich in der Universität da irgendwo gespeichert habe, da unendbar. Aber da darf nur so ganz nebenbei. Aber eigentlich wollte ich ja auch auf den Führerschein hinaus, und zwar ist es, meine Frage ist nämlich, wenn ich meinen Führerschein habe, da ist ja auch irgendwie, dann muss ja mein Alter auf dem Führerschein irgendwie gespeichert sein, bzw. auch mein, ja, ich weiß nicht, ob da meine Namen und meine gesamten Stammdaten gespeichert sind, wenn ich die dann in diesen Zigarettenautomat mal reinstecke, um mir dann Zigaretten zu kaufen, wird es dann gespeichert oder wie funktioniert das dann?
Auf jeden Fall machen Sie einen Vermerk in deinen Führerschein, dass Rauchen ungesund ist.
Der Führerschein ist gar nicht elektronisch, ne?
Nee, der Führerschein ist nicht elektronisch. Da ist unten die Maschinenlesbare Zone drauf zurzeit.
Genau, Maschinenlesbare Zone kennt ihr auch vom Personalausweis. Das sind so zwei Zeilen, mehr oder weniger kryptische, ne, eigentlich nicht kryptische, sondern lesbare Zeichen, aber sehen halt so ein bisschen in einer besonderen Schrift. Das ist eine sehr einfache, ja, Maschinenlesbare, deswegen heißt die Maschinen- readable Zone Maschinenlesbare Zone. Ist auch wichtig bei den neuen Reisepässen. Das ist ein, da wird ein spezieller Code raus erzeugt, mit dem man dann mit dem Chip sprechen kann, also das Lesegerät dann mit dem Chip sprechen kann. Und bei den Zigarettenautomaten ist es so, wir haben da vorher noch schonmal drüber gesprochen, hier bei uns intern, wir sind ja alle nicht Raucher, deswegen war da nicht so Firmen drin. Aber man kann, glaube ich, auch einen Personalausweis da reinstecken, der wird dann irgendwie auch eingelesen. Bei manchen Geräten, ja.
Ja, da ist halt größer, deswegen geht das nicht bei allen.
Genau, und da ist dann quasi wie so ein kleiner Scanner drin, der irgendwie die Schrift einscannt, die da drauf ist. Und dann gibt es irgendwie so, kann man auch so ein Prüf-Summenverfahren machen, wo man also quasi Quersumme, Prüf-Summe erzeugt. Da gibt es übrigens, möchte ich mal drauf hinweisen, es gibt eine ganz gute Webseite für, wo das Ganze gesammelt ist, die heißt www.prüfziffernberechnung.de. Da habe ich auch noch gerade etwas über Payback gefunden. Könnte aber auch selbst klicken, wollte ich gerade noch kurz noch erwähnen, weil die Frage vorher aufkam bei Payback. Da ist es genau erklärt, was auf der Karte drauf ist. Also da ist irgendwie so eine Kennung für den Laden, quasi wo man die bekommen hat, wer einen geworben hat. Und eine Kundennummer und auch so ein Prüfziffer, mehr ist da nicht drauf. Das gibt es bei Prüfziffernberechnung, die haben dann eine ganz gute Sammlung von diesen ganzen Sachen. Und das ist eigentlich auch oftmals die erste Anlaufstelle, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie einen obskuren Code habe irgendwo und ich will wissen, was steht da eigentlich drin. Also zum Beispiel Reisepass, was ist da in diesen Zeilen und kodiert.
Aber jetzt zurück zur Frage von Johannes. Speichert der Zigarettenautomat jetzt, dass Johannes bei Ihnen Zigaretten gekauft hat, und zwar an dem und dem Tag. Und außerdem seit so und so lange seinen Führerschein hat.
Können tut sie das natürlich. Ich glaube, wir müssen einfach mal darauf vertrauen, dass sie das nicht tun.
Oder dass es ihnen zu aufwendig ist, das zu tun, weil da muss man dann Speicher rein tun, muss den auslesen, auswerten und so weiter. Sie haben selber schon genug damit zu tun, Zigaretten zu verkaufen.
Na, es hätte ja sein können, dass sie das dann speichern. Und dann irgendwie, was weiß ich nicht, in 20 Jahren bin ich dann mal, wenn ich vielleicht noch irgendeine Krankheit habe, dass dann von der Krankenkasse gesagt wird, ja, sie rauchen ja aber schon seit dem und dem Zeitpunkt. Und sie haben ja in dem und dem Zeitpunkt Zigaretten gekauft. Und deswegen, weiß ich ja nicht.
Ja, im Zweifelsfall, wenn du Zigaretten kaufst, Ich hab die mal für meinen kleinen Bruder geholt. Ja, für irgendjemand mitbringst, ist ja was anderes. Aber solltest du in 20 Jahren krank werden, weil du geraucht hast, dann wird dein Arzt auch sehen, dass du seit 20 Jahren rauchst. Das Szenario ist durchaus interessant.
Das kann ja auch genauso auf die Fertigpizza im Supermarkt, auf der Paybackkarte zutreffen. Das sind alles so Fragen, die natürlich immer so das Horror-Szenario sind, bei diesen ganzen Kundenkarten, Identifikationsgeschichten. Bei der Geldkarte, wie gesagt, wir vertrauen mal darauf, dass sie nicht passiert.
Was lernen wir Johannes? Fertigpizza nicht rauchen. Chaosradio auf Fritz Nummer 135. Wir reden über Plastikkarten, die ihr mit euch rumführt auf den Magnetstreifen oder Chips oder RFID-Chips oder sonst was drauf ist, auf denen Daten gespeichert sind. Und wo ihr euch vielleicht fragt, was steht da eigentlich drauf? Würde ich immer schon mal gerne wissen. Die Jungs vom CCC können euch da helfen.
Genau, und ich wollte eigentlich nochmal kurz anmerken, dass ihr uns auch per E-Mail erreichen könnt auf chaosradio.de Und ich möchte außerdem noch auf unseren Ableger sozusagen in Chaosradio Express hinweisen, immer mal wieder, wo unsere ganzen oder wo einige unsere Themen und auch viele mehr in aller Tiefe besprochen werden. Das Chaosradio Express macht der Tim hauptsächlich. Das ist nur ein klassischer Podcast, kommt also nicht im Radio. Und ist also die Möglichkeit, mal, wenn ihr bei Themen mal ein bisschen länger hinhören wollt, die sind so meist eine Stunde oder auch mal zwei, wenn man ins Plaudern kommt. Und da sind so die ganzen Sachen, die wir hier eigentlich nur anschneiden können, werden da dann mal in aller Tiefe besprochen.
Wir werden nach den Nachrichten noch aufs Thema Packstation eingehen, auch Karte, die wir noch nicht hatten und natürlich auch Schließsysteme, wie man da so rein und raus kommt. Martin und Manuel wollen was dazu sagen. Jungs, habt ein bisschen Geduld. Wir machen Nachrichten. Danach seid ihr dran.
Fritz präsentiert eine der besten Livebands dieses Planeten. Und Berlins. Und das Abschlusskonzert ihrer Europa Tournee. Fritz präsentiert die Beatstakes. Karten gibt's überall wo's Karten gibt. Und Zusatzkonzerte auf keinen Fall. Dafür aber mehr Infos. Freitag, 29.
August.
Die Beat Stakes.
Präsentiert von Fritz.
Und das hört man.
23.32.
CSU-Chef Erwin Huber unterstützt die Forderung der Milchbauer nach einem höheren Milchpreis. Er hatte einen Milchpreis von mehr als 40 Cent für angemessen, sagt er dem Münchner Merkur. Der Bundesverband Deutscher Milchviehhalter fordert einen Basispreis von 42 Cent pro Liter da der Preis für Milch in den letzten Monaten stark gesunken ist. Fast alle Mitglieder des Verbands protestieren nun und haben ihre Milchlieferungen eingestellt. Engpässe in Supermärkten soll es noch nicht geben. Vertreter aus über 100 Ländern haben sich bei einer Konferenz in Dublin auf ein Verbot von Streubomben geeinigt. Die tödlichen Waffen öffnen sich in der Luft und können viele kleine Sprengsets über ein weites Gebiet verteilen. Da diese oftmals nicht sofort detonieren, bleiben sie als Landminen liegen. Die weltweit wichtigsten Produzenten und Anwender von Streubomben, die USA, Israel, China, Russland, Indien und Pakistan, nahmen an der Konferenz allerdings nicht teil. Deutschland will mehr Geld für den Erhalt der tropischen Regenwälder ausgeben. Auf der UNO-Konferenz zum Schutz der Artenvielfalt in Bonn kündigte Bundeskanzlerin Merkel an, die Bundesrepublik werde von 2013 an jährlich eine halbe Milliarde Euro bereitstellen, um das Abholzen der Wälder zu stoppen. Auch andere Industrieländer sollen sich dadurch ermutigt fühlen, sich für den Regenwald in den Entwicklungsländern einzusetzen. Neapel hat sich nach 240 Jahren als Monarchie zur Republik erklärt. Den Beschluss dazu fällt die verfassungsgebende Versammlung. Im künftigen Parlament werden die Maoisten die stärkste Fraktion und somit vermutlich auch den Regierungschef stellen. Sie hatten die Monarchie mit Waffengewalt bekämpft. In dem Konflikt sind in den vergangenen zehn Jahren mehr als 13.000 Menschen getötet worden. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen Angermünde 13 Grad, Frankfurt 17, Potsdam, Cottbus, Neuropin und Wittenberge 18 Grad und in Berlin um die 18 Grad. Heute Nacht gibt es nur wenig Wolken, es bleibt meist trocken. Vereinsierte Schauer gibt es nur in Richtung Fleming und Dosse und die Temperaturen gehen runter auf 14 bis 10 Grad. Morgen wird es dann wieder schön sonnig, aber mit ein paar Wolken und Regnen soll es dabei nicht. Die Temperaturen steigen auf maximal 25 bis 29 Grad. A13 Berlin Richtung Dresden, zwischen Dreieck Spreewald und Groß-Räschen fährt ein Schwertransport. Überholen ist hier nicht möglich.
Nachrichtenwetterverkehr mit Liane Gruß, vielen Dank.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Und wenn im Radio 91, 9?
Dann Fritz rund um Welt sich.
Blumen, die zwei Sprechstunden.
Die junge Frau kommt aus Schweden, heißt Luckeli. Das war der Black Kids Remix. Und die komplette Playliste der Sendung gibt es natürlich auf fritz.de. Ihr seid im Chaos Radio Teil 135 auf Fritz mit dem Chaos Computer Club. Henrik und Frank sind hier. Wir haben noch knapp 20 Minuten Zeit, um über Plastikkarten zu reden, auf denen Daten von euch gespeichert sind, wo ihr immer schon mal fragen wolltet. Was ist das eigentlich? Wir hatten schon die Mensa-Karte, die Karte für den Geldautomaten, die Karten, mit denen man im Bus oder in der Bahn bezahlt per RFID-Chip. Was ist eigentlich mit Rabattkarten, mit so Bank- und Geldkarten? Und Manuel hat noch eine weitere Karte mit ins Spiel einzuwerfen, nämlich die wunderbare Karte der Packstation. Hallo Manuel. Schönen guten Abend.
Du willst wissen, wie die Packstation-Karte funktioniert?
Ja, genau. Also an sich fand ich die Idee von der Packstation eine ganz gute, weil ich dann eben nicht mehr zur Post rennen muss, wenn ich gerade wieder Post verpasst habe.
Es fehlt mir so ein bisschen die automatische Umleitung zur Packstation.
Bitte?
Es fehlt mir so ein bisschen die automatische Umleitung von Paketen an meine Adresse an die Packstation.
Ja gut, wobei das wär dann ja auch nicht unbedingt so praktisch, weil dann wissen wir nicht an welche Packstation. Ich bin ja mal da, mal da. Aber jetzt mal davon abgesehen, mir ist dann ja gleich das Grauen gekommen, als ich den gesamten Prozess da kennengelernt hab, weil einmal, wenn ich mich recht erinnere, war meine Handynummer ein absolutes Lichtfeld, als ich mich da angemeldet hab.
Ja, weil die Packstation dir eine SMS schickt, weil sie dir sagte, dein Paket ist da.
Und jetzt hab ich halt da noch eine weitere Karte im Geldbeutel. Im Prinzip weiß ich überhaupt nichts über die Karte, was ist da drauf. Ja, und abgesehen davon, dass ich mir die Pinnig merken kann, wird mich das eben interessieren.
Wie sieht denn die aus? Ist das eine Magnetstreifenkarte oder?
Goldkarte, so eine goldene Karte, hat auch so eine Nummer. Und Magnetstreifen sieht im Prinzip aus wie all diese Kundensammelkarten.
So, hm. Es geprägt hat sogar einen Posthologramm drauf. Die sieht ja gleich aus. Und in Unterschriften fällt da nichts. Ja, Magnetstreifen würde ich mal sagen.
Ja, Magnetstreifen mit PIN. Und eigentlich brauchst du die auch zum einen, um wenn die Parkstation in einem geschlossenen Bereich ist, um in den Bereich reinzukommen.
Ah, wobei es gibt, das haben wir vorhin schon gehört, es gibt Poststellen, da kommst du mit der Parkstationkarte nicht rein, sondern du musst dich entweder per EC oder per Kreditkarte legitimieren, um überhaupt an die Parkstation ranzukommen, wo man sich natürlich die Frage stellen muss, wieso muss ich da zu einer EC-Karte ziehen?
Bei meiner Post war das so, dass man die Karte gar nicht ganz reinstecken konnte und deswegen konntest du Magnetstreifen nicht ganz lesen. Es ging jede Karte mit Magnetstreifen, Hauptdarmagnetstreifen.
Da hast du aber eine glückliche Post gehabt. Ja.
Ja, also im Prinzip würde ich... Wir können jetzt auch nichts Genaues darüber sagen, was da drauf gespeichert ist, oder?
Na, da wird deine Nummer drauf sein und das wird es wahrscheinlich im Wesentlichen sein.
Na, da hätte ich noch einen Einwurf, weil es gibt ja auch so private Parkstationen. Also solche, die man nicht über die Post-Webseite findet, wo man praktisch die Nummer wissen muss und nur dann da hinschicken kann. Also zum Beispiel bei meiner Firma im Keller steht auch so eine Parkstation.
So eine Art Postfach.
Die ist nur für die Mitarbeiter gedacht. Und da würde mich jetzt natürlich interessieren, ob man praktisch nur die Nummer wissen muss, um die dahin zu senden, oder ob ich jetzt auch eine Parkstationkarte brauche, eine spezielle, und ob da praktisch zum Beispiel mein Arbeitgeber drauf gespeichert ist.
Na, ich würde jetzt mal ganz vorsichtig ins Dunkel hinein theoretisieren. Also wo das Paket hingeschickt wird, ist ja im Endeffekt egal. Wenn du es nicht abholen kannst und die Karte nicht hast, schicken sie sie einfach wieder zurück und melden sich dann irgendwie nochmal bei dir. Und wenn du eine Parkstation, eine private, bei dir bei deinem Arbeitgeber hast, dann ist ja klar, dass die bei deinem Arbeitgeber steht, weil da steht ja dann nicht drauf irgendwie Michael Müller, sondern Wasserfirma XY, Parkstation Nummer, und dann kommt irgendeine Zahl. Da steht ja vorne schon obendrauf, wo diese Parkstation steht. Also da glaube ich nicht, dass da irgendwie ein Problem geben würde. Aber wie gesagt, es ist absolut gefährliches Halbwissen. Das vermute ich jetzt einfach nur.
Also ich habe auf die Schnelle auch irgendwie gerade nichts im Netz gefunden. Kann mir zwar nicht vorstellen, dass sich das noch niemand angesehen hat in Magnetstreifen, aber wir werden das mal bei Gelegenheit tun.
Wir haben ein Auge drauf.
Genau, schick uns mal, wenn du es wissen willst, schick uns mal eine Mail an chaosradio.ccc.de. Kann aber irgendwie ein, zwei Wochen dauern.
Parkstation hätten wir erklärt, was wir auf gar keinen Fall noch vergessen sollten, ist das Thema Schließsysteme und so Eingangskarten, wenn man irgendwo in einen speziellen Raum will. So was zum Beispiel dazu hat Martin angerufen. Hallo Martin. Von wo rufst du an? Aus Dresden, alles klar. Oh, da findet ja, kann man gleich nochmal sagen, in Dresden findet ja am kommenden Wochenende Datenspuren statt.
Nicht kommendes Wochenende, ein später, am 7. 8. Juni.
Bei mir, ja stimmt.
Genau, also 10 Tagen sozusagen, genau, in der Scheune. Irgendwie von morgens bis abends, kostet nichts. Und da gibt es irgendwie CCC-Vorträge.
Und da kommt man aber auch nur rein, wenn man eine Zugangskarte hat. Nein, Quatsch. Martin, was hast du mit dem Schließsystem für ein Problem?
So, also vor etwas längerer Zeit habe ich mal ein Praktikum gemacht bei einem großen deutschen Elektronikkonzern. Und habe ich einen Mitarbeiterausweis bekommen. Und den Ausweis brauchte ich, um zu meinem Arbeitsplatz zu kommen. Der war in so einem Sicherheitsbereich. Jetzt nicht irgendwie, weil da ein Reaktor in der Nähe steht oder so, sondern einfach nur, weil die ein bisschen Angst vor Industriespionage hatten. Jedenfalls musste ich dann halt immer, um zu meinem Arbeitsplatz zu kommen, durch so eine große schwere Staltür durch, die sich nur eröffnete, wenn ich dann mein Mitarbeiterausweis an so ein Lesegerät gehalten habe. Also es war vermutlich mal AFID. Der Trick am Ganzen war jetzt, dass die Toilette befand sich zum Beispiel außerhalb dieses Sicherheitsbereiches. So, dass ich immer irgendwie das Gefühl hatte, dass mein Arbeitgeber dann auch sehr genau protokolliert, wann ich dann nun auf Toilette gehe oder rausgehe, eine rauchen oder halt zum Mittagessen gehe. Und das finde ich jetzt nicht so toll.
Also normalerweise gibt es ja sowas wie Stechuhren in so ganzes Althergebracht betrieben. Das ist bei so Großfirmen, die es ja offensichtlich geht, ist es eine Sache, die auch die Arbeitnehmervertretung, also sprich der Betriebsrat, dann auch zumindest ein Wörtchen mitzureden hat und auch darüber informiert wird, was da genau ist. Und so Sachen kannst du dann auch nachfragen beim Betriebsrat. Und damit machst du dich dann auch irgendwie nicht verdächtig. Also eigentlich, wenn der Betriebsrat wirklich vertrauenswürdig ist, dann ist es auch kein Problem, dass du danach fragst, wie ist das, was wird denn eigentlich gespeichert? Und die sollten in der Lage sein, dir darüber Auskunft zu geben. Also diese Zutrittskarten gibt es eigentlich bei vielen großen Firmen. Da wird dann wahrscheinlich schon registriert, wer wann durch welche Tür gegangen ist. Allein wenn jetzt irgendwo, keine Ahnung, dann doch mal irgendwo was geklaut wird, in ein Büro oder sowas, dann kann man sehen, wer von den Mitarbeitern potenziell da jetzt in dem Bereich ist. Das ist natürlich ziemlich heikel, weil, ja, wer sagt denn, dass ich da denn wirklich war? Also nur, dass meine Kartenkennung da in diesem Lesingerät gelandet ist, heißt ja nicht, dass ich oder überhaupt nur meine Karte da tatsächlich auch gewesen ist.
Naja, zu den Berufen gibt es ja aber, wenn das wirklich Hochsicherheitsbereiche sind, gibt es ja meistens auch eine Kamera, die da hängt, die das zusätzlich beobachtet.
Ja, also im Zweifelsfall sieht ihr dann auch nur, dass du irgendwie eine Nase und irgendwie zwei Ohren hast. Also diese RFID Geschichten, die sind, die sind oftmals nicht so sicher wie die Verkäufer, die einem so ein System aufspatzen überhaupten. Da haben wir ja schon irgendwie einiges gehabt. Klassikerweise oder der wahrscheinlich schlimmste Fall, in Anführungszeichen, war die Geschichte um MyFair. Es gibt aber auch andere Systeme, die viel einfacher sind, welche quasi gar keine oder praktisch gar keine Verschlüsselung haben, die man irgendwie mit einem iPod quasi oder mit einem MP3-Player.
Gar keine Verschlüsselung ist sehr, sehr weit verbreitet. Ich hatte das bei mir an der Uni. Da hatten wir ein sehr altes, naja gut, sehr altes System aus 1998 von der Firma NEDAP, was aber eher so nach 80er-Jahre-Technologie aussah. Einfache weiße Karten, die, wenn sie in das Lesegerät erzeugt, erzeugt ein Magnetfeld, ein wechselndes Magnetfeld. Wenn man die Karte reinhält, dann fängt sie an, ihre Identifikationsnummer rauszusenden. Was einen schon einmal hätte stutzig machen sollen, ist, dass es die Lesegeräte von derselben Firma auch im drei Meter reichweiten Bereich gibt, sodass man einfach bloß auf die Tür zugehen muss, damit sie anfängt, sich zu öffnen. Was vielleicht jemand, der das kauft, so ein bisschen hätte stutzig machen können. Ich hab mir das mal angesehen und so rausgefunden, dass es wirklich nur die Nummer sendet, hab die Nummer dann aufgezeichnet auf ein beliebiges Audiogerät, weil die mit sehr geringer Bitrate gesendet wurde, also ein iPod zum Beispiel. Und hab dann eine einfache Kartenattrappe gebaut, also sieht nicht mal so ähnlich aus wie eine Karte, sondern einfach bloß eine Spule mit drei Bauteilen dran, an den iPod anschließen, die richtige Audiodatei abspielen und die Tür öffnet sich. Das sind die ganz einfachen Systeme, die nur eine Nummer auslesen. Das ist erstaunlich weit verbreitet oder erschreckend weit verbreitet. Wir haben in dem anderen Gebäude der Universität auch so ein Schließkartensystem, was dann auf Myfair basiert. Myfair hat eigentlich Sicherheitsfunktionen, die in dem System aber nicht weiter verwendet werden. Es liest einfach auch bloß die Nummer aus. Da ist dann die Schaltung nicht mehr nur 3 Euro teuer, sondern 40 Euro teuer. Man kann es trotzdem sehr einfach umgehen. Dann gibt es Systeme, die mit Verschlüsselung arbeiten, wo zum Beispiel das Lesegerät was zur Karte hinschickt. Die Karte muss dann mit einer verschlüsselten Version davon antworten. Da ist, weil die preiswert sein sollen, baut man dann meistens nicht ordentliche Verschlüsselung ein, sondern irgendwas, was man sich beim Frühstück selber ausgedacht hat. In Amerika ist es vielen Leuten auf die Füße gefallen, mit dem Texas Instruments Digital Signature Transponder. Da hat sich eine Forschergruppe hingesetzt und einfach mal herausgefunden, wie das Ding funktioniert und konnte sie danach machen. Sehr gerne eingesetzt bei zum Beispiel Wegfahrsperren, also Autos, ist im Prinzip auch ein Zugangskontrollsystem.
Aber auch an Tankstellen in den USA.
Genau. Und die andere Sache ist dann MyFair. Da ist schon ein bisschen mehr Sicherheit drin. Da ist der Schlüssel etwas länger. Das Verfahren ist auch nicht bekannt, war nicht bekannt. Wir haben es Ende des letzten Jahres veröffentlicht und da hat sich eine Forschergruppe in den Niederlanden hingesetzt, hat da ein bisschen weiter aufbauend auf unseren Ergebnissen weitergeforscht. Und dahin ist dann aufgefallen, dass das Schließkartensystem, was das niederländische Verteidigungsministerium und Innenministerium überall einsetzt, schwere Probleme hat bei der Implementierung dieses Verfahrens, sodass man einfach bloß an ein Lesegerät rangehen konnte. Man hält dann so eine falsche Karte davor, lässt sie ein bisschen was tun, setzt sich wieder zurück, trinkt einen Tee während der Computer ein bisschen rechnet und kann anschließend das Schließkartensystem umgehen. Als sie das dann dem niederländischen Inlandsgeheimdienst vorgestellt haben, ist das Innenministerium so ein bisschen nervös geworden, hat erstmal in den wichtigsten Bereichen bewaffnete Zusatzfachen aufgestellt.
Es gibt Dinge, die man eigentlich gar nicht im Detail wissen will.
Und dann gibt es sehr selten auch Systeme, die mit ordentlicher Verschlüsselung arbeiten.
Martin, danke für den Anruf. Uns läuft nämlich ein kleines bisschen die Zeit weg. Wir haben jetzt über Packstationen noch geredet, über Schließsysteme. Wir wollen auf jeden Fall noch das Thema SIM-Karten ansprechen.
SIM-Karten, genau. Das sind die kleinen Dinge, die ein Telefon hat.
Die im Wesentlichen dafür, also die erste breite Anwendung einer Smartcard waren. Und zur weltweiten Verbreitung.
Wie heißen die?
Subscriber Identity Multimodule.
Genau. Und das sind eigentlich ganz normale Chip-Karten oder ganz normale Karten. Nur, ihr kennt es ja, wenn ihr die neu bekommen habt, dann brecht ihr die einfach raus. Also die sind einfach von der Größe her kleiner, weil der Chip auf so einer Telefonkarte oder auf irgendeiner, was auch immer, Karte, der ist eigentlich auch nur so groß, wie der Chip ist oder nie. Es ist viel, viel kleiner, der eigentlich die Chip, das Große nur die Kontakte, womit man das Ding dann ins Gerät reinstecken kann, womit die Kontakte hergestellt werden. Deswegen sind diese SIM-Karten für Telefone so klein.
Die waren früher mal größer. Früher hatten die richtig die große Form, wie heute der Führerschein, also das ID.1-Format.
Das waren dann noch die Auto-Telefone.
Ja, das war eigentlich so gedacht, dass die Handys teuer werden sollen und man dann halt einfach für jedes Familienmitglied so eine SIM-Karte hat und dann ständig die SIM-Karten wechselt. Deswegen waren die so groß und meistens der SIM-Karten-Slot auch noch von außen zugänglich. Die Preisentwicklung bei Handys hat sich dann so ein bisschen anders entwickelt. Deswegen sind die heute immer in kleiner Form zum reinstecken. Die Amerikaner haben das gleich weggelassen, die SIM-Karten. Da ist dann die Nummer an das Handy gebunden.
Ja, was es drin ist, ist eine Kartennummer. Ich bin da ein bisschen überfordert.
Es ist eine richtige Smartcard. Das heißt, sie hat Kryptografiefunktionen, leichte zumindest mit einem besonderen Algorithmus. Sie hat eine PIN und überprüft auch einen Fehlbedienungszähler. Man hat nur so und so viele Versuche, die PIN einzugeben, bevor sie gesperrt wird. Man kann da drin Telefonbucheinträge speichern, eine Handvoll. Man kann da drin SMS speichern, eine Handvoll Ein- und Ausgehende. Und die Karte überprüft dann, also man muss halt die PIN eingeben, wenn es dann eingestellt ist. Man kann auch die PIN-Prüfung abschalten, bevor man auf die Telefonbucheinträge oder die SMS zugreifen kann. Und die besondere Funktionalität, wofür das Ding eigentlich da ist, dass da ein Schlüssel drin ist, ein Geheimer, ein symmetrischer Schlüssel. Und ein Geheimer, oder zumindest früher Geheimer Algorithmus, Krypto-Algorithmus, Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus ist drin, mit dem sich dann die SIM-Karte gegenüber dem Netzwerk, also es gibt dann ein Gegenstück irgendwo bei deinem Netzbetreiber, gegen den sich dann die SIM-Karte authentisiert, damit dann der Netzbetreiber weiß, das ist jetzt die echte SIM-Karte und die darf jetzt telefonieren.
Haben wir sonst noch in irgendeiner Form eine Karte vergessen, die wir zu erwähnen hätten von der großen Liste? Wir hatten krass mal zusammen, worüber wir geredet haben, heute im Chaos Radio, über Mensa-Karten, über Karten am Geldautomat, über EC-Karten, über die Karten im Verkehrsverbund, die zum Busticket kaufen zum Beispiel zu benutzen sind. Wir haben über die Problematik gesprochen, sich zu legitimieren, zum Beispiel an irgendeinem Verkaufsautomat, sei es ein Zigarettenautomat oder was auch immer, welche Daten speichern die da, über Rabattkarten, was steht auf diesen Dingern eigentlich drauf. Wir hatten die Packstation, wir hatten Zugangskarten, wir haben über SIM-Karten geredet. Hier steht noch auf der großen Liste Videotheken. Dann steht hier noch Mitgliederausweise. Und hier steht noch Hoteltür.
Hoteltür, da hat irgendwie keiner zu angerufen. Wir haben es von uns aus auch nicht geschafft. Da gibt es ziemlich viele verschiedene Systeme. Am weitesten verbreitesten sind eigentlich die Magnetkarten, würde ich mal sagen, oder sehr verbreitet. Und da ist es in der Regel so, dass da eine Zimmernummer und ein Checkout-Datum, also bis wann man das Zimmer gebucht hat, draufgeschrieben ist. Und dann steckt man ja einfach in diese Tür rein, in das Lesegerät. Und das Lesegerät hat dann irgendwie eine Uhr drinne und sieht dann, aha, okay, der darf hier rein. Und es gibt da ein paar Systeme, die ein bisschen sophisticated sind, dass man also nicht einfach auf gut Glück von irgendjemanden eine Karte nehmen kann, die kopieren kann. Ich kann es mir jetzt gerade nicht zusammenreiben, wie das funktioniert. Die haben sich da was ausgedacht, dass es gehen soll.
Also es wird dann zum Beispiel in Karte und Schloss ein Zähler hochgezählt und dann der Zähler nicht übereinstimmt. Das heißt aber nicht, dass man die Karte nicht kopieren kann, sondern das heißt bloß, dass eine von den beiden Karten funktioniert. Wenn ich mit meiner kopierten Karte der erste bin, der das Hotelzimmer betritt, dann funktioniert nur meine Karte und nicht die echte.
Richtig, genau. Ja, was haben wir noch? Wir haben eine ganze Liste. Ich glaube, wir sind aber so die wichtigsten.
Wir sind die wichtigsten, glaube ich, durchgegangen.
Genau, also noch mal Chaosradio at ccc.de. Ja, wenn ihr da irgendwie noch Fragen habt, schreibt uns das ansonsten auch noch mal der Verweis auf das Wiki, auf die Mitmachs-Seite zur Sendung. Alles abzurufen unter chaosradio.ccc.de.
Ich bleibe vielleicht als Fazit zu sagen, Magnetstreifenkarten, wie ihr vorhin schon mal erwähnt habt, sind eigentlich seit über vier Jahren locker überfällig.
Seit vielen Jahren, seit ungefähr 30.
Seit über 30 Jahren, das ist was auch länger als faires. Seit langer Zeit überfällig, alt hergebracht und vollkommen unsicher, dass die Karten mit dem Chip irgendwann kommen sollen. Da wird wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen was passieren, bis die Banken alle sagen, das bringen wir mal ein. Und wir haben nicht viel mehr außer dem Rat für euch. Passt auf euren Kram auf und schreibt die Nummer nicht da auf die Karten.
Aufpassen, wo er jetzt reinsteckt.
Steht überall.
Und vielleicht beim Pin eingeben dann doch mal das Portemonnaie oder die andere Hand drüber halten. Das macht auch schon mal eine ganze Menge aus.
Wollten wir ganz kurz vielleicht nochmal zu erwähnen, wie das mit den RFID-Karten ist und der Privacy Card von Philwood?
Die Privacy Card von Philwood, das ist eine Sache, die ist glaube ich schon, das ist vor ein paar Jahren gelaufen, das ist jetzt durch. Findet ihr unter Privacy Card und vielleicht Payback oder so im Netz. Google ist da oder eure Suchmaschine der Wahl ist da mal eine ganz große Hilfe, wenn es darum geht, mal rauszufinden. Machen wir eigentlich auch nicht anders, wenn wir eine komische Karte haben. Wir gucken, wer ist der Hersteller? Magnetstreifen als Suchwort oder Chip oder sowas. Und oftmals findet da, findet man schon eine ganze Menge da. Und ansonsten schreibt er uns eine Mail.
Und bei neuen Entwicklungen mehr dann dazu an dieser Stelle. Das war's Chaosradio auf Ritz, Teil 135 am 28. Mai 2008. Hier geht's weiter mit Maxwell Smart und einem fantastischen Liveflight mit Beats, die ihr noch nie gehört habt in eurem Leben und die auch er noch nie gehört hat in seinem Leben und die so krass sind, dass er da draußen schon anfängt zu Breakdancen. Henrik, Franco und Jakob Kranz sagen Tschüss. Bis dann, machts gut.